for the first time unlv played at
allegiant stadium
8 news now reporter orco mana is outside
in orco this is just exciting for
everybody
well sasha it was a historic night and
we're going to get to the game in just a
little bit
but first we just want to mention again
that this is the first time
that fans could be inside legion stadium
for a football game and though most of
the seats were still empty inside
those who were inside had the time of
their lives now unlv
is hosting in-state rival unr in their
epic annual battle for the fremont
cannon i mean what a night to have fans
inside allegion stadium for the very
first time
we saw fans cheering on the rebels from
the stands each group
spaced out following social distancing
guidelines due to covet 19
unlv is only allowed to use three
percent of the stadium seats
so that's about two thousand of the
sixty five thousand seats that can be
filled
everyone is screened on entry and are
required to wear face coverings
and despite all the rules fans tell me
that they were thrilled to be there